this morning I spoke with and Vice
President Biden spoke with Mayor Joe
Riley and other leaders of Charleston to
express our deep sorrow over the
senseless murders that took place last
night Michelle and I know several
members of Emanuel AME Church we knew
their pastor Reverend clementa Pinckney
who along with eight others gathered in
prayer and fellowship and was murdered
last night and to say our thoughts and
prayers are with them and their families
and their community doesn't say enough
to convey the heartache and the sadness
and the anger that we feel any death of
this sort is a tragedy any shooting
involving multiple victims is a tragedy
there is something particularly
heartbreaking about a death happening in
a place in which we seek solace and we
seek peace in a place of worship mother
Emmanuel is in fact more than a church
this is a place of worship it was
founded by african-americans seeking
liberty this is a church that was burned
to the ground because its worships
worshipers worked to end slavery when
there were laws banning all black church
gatherings they conducted services in
secret when there was a non-violent
movement to bring our country closer in
line with our highest ideals some of our
brightest leaders spoke and led marches
from this churches steps
this is a sacred place in the history of
Charleston and in the history of America
the FBI is now on the scene with local
police and more of the bureau's best are
on the way to join them the Attorney
General has announced plans for the FBI
to open a hate crime investigation we
understand that the suspect is in
custody and I'll let the best of law
enforcement do its work to make sure the
justice is served until the
investigation is complete I'm
necessarily constrained in terms of
talking about the details of the case
but I don't need to be constrained about
the emotions that tragedy is like this
race I've had to make statements like
this too many times communities like
this have had to endure tragedies like
this too many times we don't have all
the facts but we do know that once again
innocent people were killed in part
because someone who wanted inflict harm
had no trouble getting their hands on a
gun now is the time for mourning and for
healing but let's be clear at some point
we as a country will have to reckon with
the fact that this type of mass violence
does not happen in other advanced
countries
it doesn't happen in other places with
this kind of frequency and it is in our
power to do something about it I say
that recognizing the politics in this
town for clothes a lot of those avenues
right now but it'd be wrong for us not
to acknowledge it and at some point it's
going to be important for the American
people to come to grips with it and for
us to be able to shift how we think
about the issue of gun violence
collectively the fact that this took
place in a black church obviously also
raises questions about a dark part of
our history this is not the first time
that black churches have been attacked
and we know that hatred across races and
faiths pose a particular threat to our
democracy and our ideals the good news
is I'm confident that the outpouring of
unity and strength and fellowship and
love across Charleston today from all
races from all faiths from all places of
worship in the great indicates the
degree to which those old vestiges of
hatred can be overcome that certainly
was dr. King's hope just over 50 years
ago after four little girls were killed
in a bombing in a black church in
birmingham alabama he said they lived
meaningful lives and they died nobly
they say to each of us dr. King said
black and white a life that we must
substitute courage for caution they say
to us that we must be concerned not
merely with who murdered them but about
the system the way of life the
philosophy which produced the murders
their death says to us that we must work
passionately and unrelentingly for the
realization of the American dream and if
one will hold on he will discover that
God walks with him and the God is able
to lift you from the fatigue of despair
to the buoyancy of hope and transform
dark and desolate valleys into sunlit
paths of inner peace Reverend Pinckney
and his congregation understood that
spirit their Christian faith compelled
them to reach out not just to members of
their congregation or to members their
own communities but to all in me they
open their doors to strangers who might
enter a church in search of healing or
redemption mother Emanuel Church and his
congregation of risen before from flames
from an earthquake mother dark times to
give hope to generations of
Charlestonians and with our prayers and
our love and the buoyancy of hope it
will rise again now as a place of peace